خذ الأردن كأول دولة تمنح
اللاجئين نفس الوصول إلى لقاحات فيروس كورونا
مثل مواطنيها جيدًا ، أردت أن أعرف
المزيد عن ذلك ،
لذا التقيت بالملكة رانيا كجزء
من قمة وارويك الاقتصادية في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع وسألتها
جلالتها عن القضية  للتأكد من
أن كل شخص
لديه حق الوصول العادل
لتحصينه ،
فهذا جزء من محادثتنا ، من
الضروري التأكد من أن
المساواة في اللقاح
هي أولوية بالنسبة لنا لأنك تعلم
أن لدينا سحابة معلقة فوق رؤوسنا
جميعًا  ليس فقط الدول الفقيرة
سواء كنت غنيًا
أو فقيرًا سواء كنت من ذوي الدخل المرتفع أو
منخفض الدخل
لدينا سحابة من التفاوت
علينا وهذا التفاوت ليس فقط من حيث
كيفية تأثر الناس
ببعض أكثر من  الآخرين
ولكن أيضًا على قدرتنا على التعافي ، فأنت
تعلم أن هذا الوباء قد كشف حقًا
وعزز تصدعات
في نظامنا العالمي كما تعلمون على طول خطوط
عدم المساواة في الدخل وعدم المساواة بين الجنسين
socia  الظلم ولا يمكنك إضافة
عدم المساواة الصحية فوق ذلك الذي
تعرفه ، لذلك
من الضروري للغاية أن نتعامل
حقًا مع
هذه القضايا إذا لم نكن مدفوعين
بمسؤولية أخلاقية أو أخلاقية ، فعلى
الأقل يجب أن يكون لدينا دافع من
وجهة نظر الصحة العالمية ،
أتساءل عما إذا كنت تعتقد أنه نظرًا لأن
الفقراء
يزدادون فقرًا خاصة في
البلدان النامية حتى مثل
الأردن نفسه ، ما إذا كنت تعتقد
أننا سنشهد
أزمة أخرى للعولمة
وما مدى
فعالية القيادة في اعتقادك
ويمكن أن تمضي قدمًا.
أن الكثير يتعرض للاعتداء
لأول مرة منذ
20 عامًا ، لقد عاد الفقر المدقع في
الارتفاع
، لذا فقد أظهر هذا الوباء حقًا
ضوءًا
على الشقوق الموجودة مسبقًا في نظامنا العالمي
، لقد عزز بالفعل وكشف
التشققات على طول خطوط عدم المساواة
مثل  لقد ذكرت سابقًا ما إذا كان الظلم الاجتماعي بسبب
العرق
والجنس وكل هذه القضايا التي فشلنا في
معالجتها
في الماضي ومرة أخرى هذ
هو c  ترديد حالة خطيرة
للغاية مزعزعة للاستقرار
لنا جميعًا